hello everyone and welcome to what could
very well be the greatest classical game
anyone ever played against Magnus
Carlsen it's from the 2017 Norway chess
I was suggested to me by ozarov he asked
if I had seen seen this game previously
and it was right about the time when I
started my channel I think I started
like a few months after Norway chess
2017 so I I never actually covered the
games from Norway chess 2017 and this
game it's uh an absolutely stunning
Masterpiece so you guys uh really will
enjoy it and for those of you who are
maybe seeing it for the first time you
you're not gonna believe that such a
such a thing is even possible in
classical chess so let's check it out uh
Levon with the white pieces opens with
Ponte D4 if you're wondering what's with
the weird ratings those are the ratings
from uh June 2017 so I wanted to make
everything uh as authentic as possible
so the for the five by Magnus uh we have
C4 C6 Knight to F3 and now Knight to F6
this love defenses on the board we have
Knight to C3 and E6 transposing into the
semi-slav defense with E3 at the main
line we have A6 and B3 now this is all
standard stuff even today uh Bishop to
B4 and Bush of the D2
uh Bishop the beat you might look a bit
more natural but it's only been played
why uh once and uh White lost that game
so Play Bishop to D2 here Knight beat
the D7 with Bishop to D3 and now both
players just Castle castles castles and
now comes Queen to E7 nowadays the more
popular reply is Bishop back to D6 but
this is probably this game is probably
one of the reasons why Bishop to D6 is
more popular nowadays so Queen to E7 by
Magnus and now uh you would expect
something like Queen to C2 you develop
the queen you connect the Rooks you put
pressure on H7 uh does seem like the way
to develop your pieces but Levon plays
best should be back to C2 and this comes
with a very very uh particular idea that
Levon prepared uh specifically for this
game it has never been played before and
now you will see it here Magnus plays
Rook to d8 make no mistake Rook to d8 is
the top move recommended by the engine
so Magnus is not playing like a weird
moves or a weak game is playing top
engine moves up until this point and
Levon plays Ponte A3 which is weird as
Magnus is defending this uh or rather
attacking the A3 Square twice and uh it
was uh uh at this moment as a movie 11
that we had a completely new game back
in 2017 although the position has been
reached once again in 2022 but uh for
for the purposes of this video uh
consider this a completely new position
so here Bishop captures an A3 accepting
the challenge uh in the game uh from uh
20 2022 Bishop captures and C3 was
played but Magnus captures the pawn as
it is the strongest move uh recommended
by the engine and Levon does what Lavon
does best he sacrifices The Exchange
Rook captures an E3 Queen captures an A3
and now I'm sure you guys already have
an idea of of what's Happening next and
that is Pawn to C5 so Levon gives up the
exchange to trap The Black Queen here on
the queen side and there really are no
squares for the for the black queen
discovered by the Knight covered by the
Knight covered by
uh all of the other pieces and while you
could go to the dark squares then you go
under the mask of the bishop and then I
capture Sandy Fiverr and all sorts of
nasty tricks are possible so Magnus
plays B6 he wants to capture on C5 and
free up his Queen and now Levon goes for
it pawn to B4 uh he keeps the black
queen trapped here and it doesn't really
do you all that uh good if you play C
characters uh on B5 now uh on B4 now on
C5 now because Knight the B1 and what do
you do now discovered by the bishop this
is covered by the pawn you have to go to
A2 and once you go Queen to a to then
Bush up to B3 comes you will play uh
Quinta A1 and now Bishop to C3 and the
queen is trapped and you can freely
resign here so that's uh what would
happen so after B4 uh you could consider
some other ideas okay you can't capture
this but what if you play Queen captures
on B4 uh now again you just go under the
mask of the bishop Knight capture on D5
and uh well okay the queen is attacked
you have to move the queen somewhere now
comes Knight's day seven check King f8
and now you bring the bishop in Bishop
to B3 Queen to B5 You're Gonna Play
Bishop to a for Queen to B2 and now
Knight captures and C6 and this just
looks very very bad for black The Rook
is hanging you have to move the Rook
Knight after E5 and uh still the black
queen is stuck here on the queen side
and white is having a beautiful
beautiful attack here so that's uh
another thing that could happen third
thing that could happen is that okay 11
might play Queen to be a Magnus might
play Queen to B2 and this is probably
the the safest way to play it uh then we
would have Knight A4 attacking the queen
and once the queen moves now Knight to
E5 going after the C6 Pawn so captures
captures attacks the Knight Knight back
to D7 and now C capture some B6 and now
okay Magnus does get a beautiful pass
beep on uh but Levon can just go after
it Rook to B8 and the the the pawn will
fall for example Bishop the C3 you can
capture let's say Knight captures Rook
captures Queen to D4 still looks kind of
scary but you always have that Queen to
see for retreating um uh Square so it's
not uh it's not as bad
and uh it's very tricky because okay you
could capture the bishop then the Road
Kings but this is the best you have you
can't uh save the the the the Rook you
have to give back the exchange if you go
back then Queen to H4 threatens the
capture on H7 and also Now The Rook here
is hanging because the Rooks are
disconnected so that's also one of the
problems so B4 extremely complicated
move extremely complicated position but
it is the best move in the position and
Magnus uh did not go for this queen to
B2 idea he went for Knight to E4 and
look at this now Knight captures on e4 D
captures with Bishop captures on e4 and
now Rook the B8 uh Magnus just happy his
uh Queen isn't getting trapped but now
comes Bishop captures on H7 now Levon
starts a king side attack and all of a
sudden we have another Greek gift
position or is it maybe Greco's gift
position uh if from a completely weird
setup Bishop captures an H7 check King
captures this is the best move you you
have to take the bishop Knight to G5
check King goes back and in this
position it is better to go back than to
G6 and now uh Queen to H5 and now
attacking H7 but also preparing the
capture on F7 uh Magnus plays Knight to
F6 attacks the queen covers H7 now Queen
captures an F7 with check King to h8 and
now again the reason why the bishop
sacrifice is good because the Rooks are
disconnected Queen to C7 attacks both
Rooks luckily there is a way for Magnus
to save them Bishop to D7 because the
Knight here also covers the bishop
uh but now Knight to F7 check think the
H7 and Knight captures on d8 and it
seems like magnets can just resign now
because he he he just got destroyed but
he does find the absolute best way to
play this Rook the C8 challenges the
queen queen capture some B6 still keeps
an eye on the Knight and now Knights the
D5 takes away the uh this diagonal from
the White Queen Queen to A7 and this
queen to A7 is a spectacular move
because it's possible to play Queen to
B7 here and queen the A7 here and the
engine says um you know doesn't matter
at what depth you you allow the engine
to run uh says Queen A7 and queen B7 are
pretty much
um uh of equal strength and the Wilder
won't play Queen to A7 instead of Queen
to B7 is something only Lavon could tell
us so I have no idea so here Queen to A7
by Levon uh you have to give up the the
Knight here Rook captures and now comes
Pawn to E4 opening up The Bishop's
diagonal a challenging denied Queen to
C7 is coming which will be a problem for
Magnus and here Magnus should play
Knight to F6 this is what he should play
yeah it's it's a very tricky because you
allow Bishop to G5 and D5 but this is
the way to play I will just show it
because it's super fun Bishop to G5 and
now after Queen captures on B4 you will
allow E5 and now after King to G6
attacking the bishop H4 and now after
Queen capture Sun D4 you will give up
the Knight here G captures and now Queen
to B6 uh here uh The Rook is attacked so
Bishop to C8 defending the Rook with the
queen and now Bishop to E3 trying to get
the queen away from the defense of the
real queen to D5 and okay the the game
continues nothing spectacular here white
is white is a little bit better but
uh it is a very tricky position however
after E4 Magnus uh uh uh
when Queen to D3 attacking the bishop
and offering the Knight on D5 and Levon
does go for it he captures on D5 Queen
captures on D2 and now Queen to C7
attacking The Rook so Queen to G5 The
Rook cannot move otherwise the bishop
here hangs and now D captures on C6 now
creating a spectacular path Pawn on C6
with Bishop to C8 Magnus still keeping
the extra piece and now Pawn to H3 uh
just uh giving the the white king some
some reading room and now it's time to
bring the Rook into the game we have
Queen to D5 and now Rook to D1 uh we
have Pawn to E5 now if you capture then
you hang the rook and here Rook to D3 a
spectacular move by Levon uh preparing
the rock cliff The Rook is coming to G3
and then he's going after the G7 pawn
and here Magnus boldly played E Capture
Sun D4 he created a pass Pawn of his own
but now the game the game is completely
winning for
a Levon so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find this absolutely
staggering idea while I give you a
couple of seconds you you have to see
like 20 moves um deep into the position
to solve this one just giving you a
heads up so so have at it
foreign
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
um well basically a impossible spot move
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show uh it is Queen to E7
that's the move that wins the game and
that's the only move that wins the game
now like I said in order to find Queen
t7 you have to calculate everything you
really have to see 20 moves deep into
the position uh but I think either
Magnus already uh resigned this game in
his head or he didn't have time to
properly calculate it but he didn't play
the absolute best continuation he played
a move that loses the game on the spot
uh he played Bishop to F5 attacking The
Rook here which we are going to cover
uh but first I'm going to show you uh
how how this is properly defended uh had
he played Rook to G8 which makes sense
of course Lavon wants to play Rook to G3
and go for checkmate now you take care
of the immediate checkmating threat and
what is left there for for Lavon well
that's kind of what queen to E7 brings
into the game you have this queen H4
with check and now you're gonna pick up
the pawn on D4 King the G6 now you're
gonna play Rook captures on D4 and now
after Queen to E5 You're Gonna Play Pawn
to C7 this is now a spectacular
spectacular Pawn of course you cannot
capture the pawn if you capture and Rook
to D6 check and black king gets
checkmated very quickly so Rook the E8
uh and now uh you will play uh Rook to
d8 that's uh that's the point uh the The
Rook cannot move because the bishop
hangs you can never capture because the
pawn promotes so here we have a king to
F7 Now Pawn to C6 uh move after move
this is uh getting more and more
incredible Queen T1 on with checking th1
a few moves will be played here for
example uh Queen to G3 also very
important you have to know that you can
trade queens and that your position is
still winning here of course if you
capture then just King captures and uh
you you have too many pawns there's just
no good no good way to play this you're
gonna play something like King t7 hope
to capture here but then even trading
The Rook is winning for white uh yes you
do have a bishop but once those pawns
start marching forward this is
completely winning so what we would
probably see here after Queen to G3 is
Queen to F6 you would have to decline
the trade but now Rook the D7 check and
again you cannot capture because C
captures on D7 would create two
connected pass pawns on the seventh rank
that's worth more than a queen and if
Rook the E7 then you go Queen to B3 with
check King to f8 and now Rook to d8 with
check
only move is Rook 38 and once Rook d8 is
played uh Queen back to D3 and now you
are threatening the trade off the queens
and we already know that if the Queens
come off the board uh it's a winning end
game for uh for white and there's no
good way to uh to stop this you're gonna
have to play something Queen to D6 check
you're gonna have to trade and once this
happens again either Rook to d8 is
winning or you will try to stop this and
then you give up the pawn and then the
two the three connected past pawns are
just uh
uh completely winning so after Queen to
E7 this is what the Magnus should have
done and he should have tried everything
in order not to lose this game uh but uh
it was just lavon's game and not only
levon's game it was lavon's tournament
if you guys don't remember Levon uh won
at the 2017 edition of the altar box
norwich's Championship uh a full point
ahead of uh I think uh Fabiana corvana
and Vladimir kramnik so here Magnus
played Queen a bishop to F5 attacked The
Rook here but now just Rook the G3 Lavon
goes for checkmate here Bishop to G6
stopping Checkmate and now Queen to H4
check and he was in this position unmove
35 that Magnus Carlsen resigned to the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here the problem is if you block with
the queen then you hang the Rook so of
course that's impossible and if you move
the king then you hang the bishop and
well it okay it looks like black maybe
has some counter play but not really
you're just gonna play Queen t7 again
threatened checkmate and even if black
defends this you're just gonna cap Rook
captures on G7 Queen captors and queen
capture 78 with check you're gonna pick
up the D3 Pawn next if if you if you go
here then this comes with the check so
probably King F7 or queen captures here
and now you're up Five Pawns uh that's I
mean that that's just silly and what's
interesting is that this was um you can
see that Lavon was in in incredible
shape when 2793 or almost the 2800
player and um uh both of them both uh
Lavon and Magnus went into round four
this was round four uh with three draws
so this was the the big one this was the
the big clash and Lavon came out
Victorious uh which pretty much uh
ruined magnus's entire tournament but
Lavon played spectacularly and he won uh
the uh the the entire event like I said
a full point ahead of Fabi uh and
Vladimir kramnik uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it like I
said probably the the best and most
complicated and the most aesthetically
pleasing uh game anyone ever played
against Magnus Carlsen and who other
than Levon to pull it off so really hope
you enjoyed this one uh I would like to
thank Joyce Roseman uh larsism and
Thomas Phil maltus and Lauren is
pregnant for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh such as this one and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day